what's up everybody especially those of
you outside of the United States of
America criticizing our UFO trials I see
I see a lot of memes being posted by you
wait are people talking [__] yeah
they're talking [__] oh look at all the
UFO sightings in the last hundred years
they're all in America
why would they go to you that's a great
Point what reason do they have to go to
YouTube fish and chips maybe oh that
must be fun it's the changing of the
guards oh do they think they like crazy
wait to do it yeah I'll go look at the
[__] that we built in Greece thousands
of years ago y'all even build a daily as
came down helped you and now look what
you did [__] it all up stay out here
with the new generation yep that's why
they're [__] with us I'm tired of
these jealous pieces of [__] yeah
aliens Egypt that's basically the Empire
exactly Greece and Empire of the time
yes they're coming to the empires of the
time this is the Empire you visit
America you're visiting New York you're
not visiting [__] Des Moines
know what y'all look like and it's
boring over there they know what y'all
look like and it's boring over there
it's fun for us yeah we go over there
take a picture at the Acropolis yeah
okay go visit Rome calls him amazing
that's old [__] they want new new so
what are they about to build here they
just they want to try an electric car
they want to try air conditioning in the
summer Europeans don't know what the
code is they want to try a Coca-Cola
with ice it's 95 degrees out yeah we put
some ice cube in a [__]
Coca-Cola I didn't pronounce ice well I
did my best
and I do they just want to try
21st century [__] we're in the 21st
century right okay let's do it I think
so yeah now that being said that UFO
trial is complete [__]
bro it's complete it really is it really
is if you're not from America shut your
mouth aliens are not interested in you
and your shenanigans okay that don't
mean it didn't happen just because these
three are four exactly what y'all got a
windmill
we're gonna go look
at the travel light year
light you know so over to see that tiny
ass car you putter around with oh yeah
Curry yeah I'm gonna go see a Vespa it's
a mockery yeah they're making a mockery
it's a mockery of humanity that they're
making a mockery of all the technology
that the aliens have bestowed on us what
are we doing with it Fleshlight yeah do
you know what I mean Soul sucks bro
that's what we're doing I'm duck my dick
[Music]
you know what else we got that they
don't have in Europe son you said it but
central air is the greatest [__] on the
hill that's what I said what else
it what else what else we got
what else do we got God damn bro
we even got this yeah in other places
what we got a lot of teams we got
Latinas shaking ass
I mean that's true aliens what are they
gonna do they're gonna go to [__]
Great Britain see some freckled [__]
with teeth in every direction
got teeth where they from they're gonna
go there and see some Jagged tooth Welsh
[__] do you think that's what the
[__] alien wants to see no no bro
they're coming to America how is it
traveling 400 light years
because like dude there's intelligent
life if you go down that way there's a
blue planet there's intelligent life
there and you get to whales and you're
like nothing bro okay baby not too
intelligence anything they don't even
abduct them bro yeah no no they make a
left yeah dude they hit Europe and Mako
this is how bad it is they take cows
before they take them
if I had a bam bam bam
bam bam do I not get any points you get
[__] points for that that's 100
points right there I'm just saying dude
that's why they're not interested in you
guys they're not interested do you know
where aliens did go actually quite
recently Brazil oh yeah in the 80s right
yeah the Virginia incident exactly 1986.
they started narrowing [__] hair off of
them Brazilian [__] and then aliens
they created the bbls bro they created a
Brazilian oh man oh my God
come on they bring the technology that
we need yeah they bring a Brazilian butt
lift to Northern Ireland do you know
what I mean do you think they took that
home though you think the aliens got
bbos now oh
Bros they got the lips they got these
now bro aliens that was the exchange bro
of course they're gonna learn some stuff
from us we're gonna learn some stuff
from them they're gonna accentuate
everything that we have yeah you know
they're gonna accentuate everything we
had they went to Brazil bro where else
did they go
[__] I mean a lot of South America a lot
of South America
and you go to China and you just look
like everyone else there is there any
point
any like you're gonna travel 400 light
years to just be with the fam
just to be with the fam just to fit in
that's right
to be in traffic to sit in bicycle
traffic you're gonna travel 400 light
years instead of bicycle tracks is that
what y'all would want to do with this
time it's not Birthright you know
exactly
they're not going home bro what are you
doing bro they're taking a trip already
there to walk up a thousand stairs
staircases oh look at this wall you want
to see the Apple corporate office or
where they're building the iPhone thank
you thank you take me to Apple corporate
office it looks a lot like that looks a
lot like aliens [__] spaceship
a [__] spaceship that's all I'm
trying to say I see you're jealous I see
you out there with your memes trying to
talk [__] like we crazy we are
foreign
but it makes sense it makes sense they
would not come to y'all y'all living in
the past do some new [__] Europe
do some new [__]
it's getting old it's getting old how
much new new have we seen come out of
Europe nothing bro even the sports they
play all this [__] it's a sport tennis
ball to sport oh if that's a sport at
least how many sports we invented
American football
baseball football pickleball
who did patterns
no no no no you think Spain did that bro
they're not white though you know yeah
what it is they're more Moroccan they
really if you really look in Spain Spain
is really African Moors yep Morse 100
Spain is Africa built like Spanish
guitars bro
I think the aliens about it went bad bro
if I'm an alien yep
some of these aliens are kind of stacked
oh my God that's what they got from us
bro oh my God titties that looks like
that crazy one in a dog yeah yo don't
finish that [__]
exactly what
I say it that looked like it escaped out
of North Korea
that's another thing
I look just like a bird
which hold on which one I think we know
which one